YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Last time, we covered
how you can use Google Cloud
platform metrics as Service
Level Indicators to measure the
reliability of your services
and set reliability
targets using SLOs.
But what do you do if you need
custom telemetry for your SLIs?
Today, I'm going to show
you how to use Prometheus
and OpenCensus to
write custom metrics
and define SLIs and
SLOs using them.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine a basic web application
architecture like this.
While we can use the metrics
emitted by the load balancer
to track things like request
counts and response latency,
what if our application
running on GKE
needs to keep track of
specific transaction details
and write a custom
counter for them?
What if we want to use this
kind of custom telemetry
as our SLI for the service?
This is where custom
metrics come in.
Today, I'm going to
show you how to use
two open-source approaches
to custom metric telemetry.
The first one is Prometheus.
Prometheus is an
open-source systems
monitoring alerting tool
kit, originally built
with SoundCloud.
It has a very active
developer and user community
and joined the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation back
in 2016.
This is the
architecture Prometheus
uses to collect metrics.
The general idea is
that your service
needs to expose a dedicated
metrics endpoint, which
Prometheus will then scrape
to collect metric data.
That data is stored in
the time series database
and can be queried through
a web UI or an API.
We'll link to the full code
sample in the show notes,
but let's have a look
at how to instrument
an application written in NodeJS
to emit counter and histogram
metrics.
Start by defining the
metrics themselves.
For each, specify the
metric type, its name,
and a help message
that will describe
what the metric is capturing.
To track latency,
use a histogram,
and call its observe method.
To increment counters,
call their inc method.
Finally, create a dedicated
endpoint in your application
that Prometheus will use
to scrape for metrics.
The instrumentation is done.
Now, if you go to the
/metrics endpoint in your app,
you'll see a page
that looks like this.
The metrics and their
values are written out here.
Now you need to
configure Prometheus
itself to scrape this endpoint.
You do that by adding
some annotations
in the deployments spec
in your application,
enable scraping,
and define the port
and endpoint where the
metrics are available.
Next, you need to ingest these
metrics into Cloud Monitoring.
We'll link the detailed
instructions in the show notes,
but the basic idea is that you
pass your Prometheus server
with a collector that will
send these metrics to Cloud
monitoring.
Once your metrics
are available there,
you're ready to use
them for SLIs and SLOs.
Here's an example of how you can
use a latency metric, written
by Prometheus, to create
a distribution-cut SLI
and set an SLO target for it.
A distribution cut allows
you to capture the percentage
of values that fall
within a specified
threshold, as defined by range.
This SLO expects
that 98% of responses
complete within 500 milliseconds
over a rolling 28-day period.
Prometheus is a popular
open-source monitoring
framework, and it's well suited
for monitoring applications
running in GKE.
But what if you don't
want to maintain
that additional infrastructure?
In that case, you
can use OpenCensus
to write metrics directly using
the Cloud Monitoring exporter.
OpenCensus is a
single distribution
of libraries to collect
metrics and distributed traces
from your services.
Let's have a look at how
to instrument your service,
configure the Cloud
Monitoring exporter,
and use OpenCensus metrics
to define SLIs and SLOs.
Again, we'll link to the full
code samples in the show notes,
but let's take a quick
look at instrumenting
an application written in NodeJS
to emit counter and histogram
metrics.
Start by configuring the
Cloud Monitoring exporter.
This will send the metrics
you captured directly
to Cloud Monitoring, where
you will then use them
to create SLIs and define SLOs.
Next, define a measure
for each metric.
Measures describe
how the data points
themselves will be recorded.
Create a view for each measure.
Views are basically
the [INAUDIBLE]
you'll be adding data points to.
They also include
information about how
that data will be aggregated.
For our latency
histogram, you'll
need to specify your
bucket boundaries.
It's important to
at least make sure
that you have
buckets that capture
requests that are going to fall
within and outside of your SLO.
However, you'll likely
want more than just
those to allow you to, for
example, measure PINI latency.
Finally, record values
using the record method.
Unlike Prometheus,
this is the same
for counters and
histograms in OpenCensus.
You won't need to
configure any scraping.
The exporter will write
the values directly
to Cloud Monitoring.
You can then use them to
define SLOs like this.
Here's an example of
a distribution cut
SLI using the response latency
metric, written by OpenCensus,
with an SLO of 98% of
responses being completed
in under 1,000 milliseconds.
Thanks for joining me today.
In this episode, we looked at
how to instrument your code
to write custom metrics with
OpenCensus and Prometheus,
use them to define
Service Level Indicators,
and set Service Level
Objectives against those.
You're now ready to
start defining SLIs
by using these open-source
libraries in your own services.
In our next episode, we'll
look at alerting on our SLOs
with error budget burn rates.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]